no I didn't kill my wife echo hi Fox
Trot what are you doing in this okay as
mad as the whole design hey cuz I know
it's not anywhere near you guys that's
for sure
look bye
so why doesn't everybody meet me hello
nope here's nothing oh come on oh my
goodness get a shoot I gotta get a good
shot I gotta get him realsies is those
Fox Trot has the gun okay is there
punishment how'd you go but he goes if
the guy shoots the TNT will it explode
what's you guys know are you guys
officer kilo sauce burger
thank you yeah first thing I like to do
when I get to the scene of a crime is
shoot any explosives that happen to
grant it'll preserve the crime perfectly
keeps my senses sharp alright whoever
whoever rushes kilo I deemed guilty ha
ha ha
the guy go let's see you guys later
ok so kilo kilo is kilos good I'm good
uh oh I don't know about Zoo and no
Missoula like to sound if that crazy law
I always do the crazy laughs that never
works
aah ow all right all right
x-ray I got your back we do how do you
how are you gonna get my back though
like here's Harrisson I'm gonna get your
back I'm gonna go in front we Scout
where is he all right I got ya watch
those winners berries that make sure you
kill it all right uh uh wait oh you guys
are boned where were you where is this
native bone bad easily lost it you
shaking you can't even handle the power
gee sounds like a scooby-doo villain
right now oh I didn't work hey get back
here ooh I got you
oh I got a show count of three I got a
shoot there holder I got a show oh we're
gonna get shot yeah go get shot today I
don't lose your gun we're gonna get shot
while you're getting your badge Mari
calm down just think about this think
about this what do you know about all s
collectively huh you sure know a lot pop
hey
eenie meenie miney moe no that's not how
you do tiger by the toe hello easy same
can you give me back my gun Nyree now
you lost your beverage to use the gun
oh wait a minute which miss Marg I am
Papa ha do I'm Papa wait who's who I'm
keel or hiccup that's cute got a guy
meaning what are you talking about
that's me that's me no I'm Kela did you
said no I'm just wrong this group I
don't know what to do I'm thinking self
don't you guys still someone's gonna
throw their knife at you hey I said hi
like this we know Delta we know Delta's
in his first I think it's Delta I think
is Delta mommy belt the head the guy in
the beginning
okay hello the pops either Papa or kilo
it's either popular kilo solving the
crime guess if you have them standing
the lioness you can get like a
collateral or kilo stand all right stay
in the line oh that's that's true I'm
willing to sacrifice myself to the
falseness
I'm Hank I don't line we're gonna work
together we're gonna figure right bad
guy it's funny like just you two
it is one of you two okay oh nice oh my
god
depending upon what your pretty gosh oh
[ __ ]
Oh yep the corpse repeatedly agrarian
facility by a murder over there I spy a
murder we gotta go for this k can only
swipe one okay okay right all right you
ready
you go first mix you go first ha ha ha
ha shut up good make me proud
make me proud terrible person hey be
cool who's got the gun
oh wait he don't have a knife Hayes
everybody get ahead and get him shut up
you're the worst shot ever do a little
bit okay I'm an innocent dick you stand
in front of me no one gets behind me
okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh no I think
I'm down see the rabbi rabbi rabbi the
murder
yeah kill me where are you I'll use you
as because I have the gun okay okay I'll
be bait how do you think I'm okay with
this oh he's right here Mike you're
stopping he's gorgeous dummy perfectly
the old baton shoot there's a good
chance that you get a seat Oh God guns
and away ah ah
where huh all right wait oh yeah quick a
direct we're back I got a dog I don't
know how are you slipped in the air with
stop with your wizard oh yeah my lunches
are oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] get to
safety
Oh
oh yeah you weren't you can't be the
murderer twice in our Oh you okay I have
echo trapped
whoever's whoever's got a guy shoot him
I got it is the gun darkness store in
the sewers
in the sewers ease of the source I know
is the zeros right oh [ __ ] no murderer
what would you like Juliet I'd like your
head on a plate oh okay can't do that
because I need to cook the dinner okay
you were wrong
sparkles we were wrong poof who is it
did you is it second Juliet where I
could job guys
I had the gun Zulu had the girl crack
tea medicine where is everything
happening here she and I'm not sharing
any soda
markiplier yeah yeah yeah I'm just a
little trigger-happy right now so no one
getting my line of sight God it was
great do Liat Wow mom are coming back as
a magical hold me yeah oh my god I
nearly broke bread with you
sparkles you should know when he wanted
your head on the plate whoever knife
fight as well just shoot me in the face
just get it open do it I do it I'm a
monster and that's an execution that
really
shut up
what the hell is that Mon stop opening
that freaking door